[Music]
the chart I'm building shows the
greenhouse gas emissions from producing
one kilogram of some common foods in
other words it shows how much they
contribute to global climate change most
fruits and vegetables are down here with
relatively low emissions poultry and
eggs are a little further up pig
products are here coffee and chocolate
are a little higher but all of these
pale in comparison to this food it's the
worst thing we eat when it comes to
global warming this is beef when you
only account for the emissions that go
into the processing transportation
packaging and selling of a food product
the difference between these foods isn't
so great when you add the emissions from
growing and processing food for
livestock you can see that animal
products have higher emissions than
vegetables but the real gap comes from
these two factors the emissions
associated with the farming process and
the impacts of land use change coffee
has such a big footprint because of the
fertilizers farmers use to grow it which
emit a lot of the greenhouse gas nitrous
oxide the farming process also accounts
for most of the disparity between cow
and sheep products and everything else
cows and sheep have to digest food that
most animals can't do as well like grass
and tough plant material their stomachs
are microbe rich to help them do that
through a process called enteric
fermentation the byproduct of this
digestion is methane a powerful
greenhouse gas some of those emissions
come out this way but 95% come out the
front if you've never heard one of these
animals burp there's an endless supply
of YouTube videos for your viewing
pleasure jokes aside though methane is a
huge contributor to climate change it's
the second most emitted greenhouse gas
after carbon dioxide but it traps more
heat than carbon dioxide it's global
warming potential over a hundred years
is 21 times higher among human related
activities enteric fermentation is the
biggest contributor to methane emissions
globally more so even than the methane
emissions from burning fossil fuels and
it's a big reason why the farming
process related emissions for beef and
sheep are so high the second reason is
land use change starting in the 1700s
the amount of land developed for
humanity's purposes started to skyrocket
only a tiny amount of this is due to our
built environment like cities towns and
other infrastructure a vast majority is
for agriculture and when you divide that
up you see that land for grazing animals
far surpasses land for growing crops
converting all that land to farms to
make way for grazing or growing crops
releases the carbon that was once stored
in trees
other plants and the soil by contrast
nuts and citrus fruit and olive oil have
negative land-use emissions because
planting nut and citrus fruit and olive
trees is reforesting cropland
but chocolate has a lot of lien do
submissions because cacao farming
results in tropical deforestation in
Southeast Asia Africa and South America
and grazing animals take up a lot of
space compared to crops 80% of
deforestation in the Amazon rainforest
for example is to make way for cattle
ranching this is how many tons of
greenhouse gases per capita we emit
through all of our activities changing
our diet to exclude high emission foods
has the potential to reduce it by 28% by
both reducing emissions and reforesting
land that's more than any other life
change we could make a lot of food
emissions are unavoidable we have to eat
but we do have a choice of what not to
eat
[Music]